[Music]
for those of you who are wondering what
happened to the next heroes path
no worries it's still coming i
definitely plan to tie up this series in
a neat little bow however
now that the second presentation of
hyrule warriors has come and gone there
is a little less pressure to release the
last two episodes at the same speed i
did with the previous ones
we have until the end of november until
the game releases after all
episode 6 is scheduled to go up this
weekend and 7 will follow the week after
so i hope you look forward to that
in the meantime since we have a new
trailer now i thought i'd do what every
self-respecting zelda obsessed gaming
nerd does and
overanalyze stuff that most people
probably glossed over and wouldn't
even be bothered by it to begin with
today i want to talk about this specific
clip from the trailer
which is my favorite one with the
opening shot of akala citadel as a close
second
despite being only one and a half
seconds long this shot was probably a
big eye-catcher
for a lot of people as someone who has
been researching and obsessing over the
great calamity for the past weeks
this little piece of footage was just
pure eye candy
finally being able to see the immense
scale and chaos that went on in central
hyrule is
amazing also sad for the inhabitants
but amazing for me there are a couple of
things i want to go over in regards to
this shot so
let's start with some of the smaller
ones first off we finally have an idea
of just how many guardians were roaming
around central hyrule that night and
well safe to say there were a lot of
them second
aside from guardian stalkers which have
always been depicted as the main
antagonist during the invasion we can
clearly see a significant amount of
skywatches flying around as well proving
that they were just as much a part of
the forces that eradicated the
settlements garrisons and other
important landmarks across hyrule
in breath of the wild none of the
cutscenes from the calamity showed the
sky watchers in action and instead
only showed the stalkers doing the dirty
work we did see them briefly in the
first trailer for age of calamity but
only at castletown
it makes sense that they too played a
big part in the invasion since we can
still find some of them roaming around
in various locations in breath of the
wild most notably at akala citadel
so it's nice to finally see this
confirmed in an actual cutscene
another thing to note is that the
destruction of central hyrule took place
at night and in rainy weather which
matches perfectly with the cutscenes of
lincoln zelda during the event
specifically the one where zelda breaks
down and the one where link and zelda
are at fort hatteno
just the fact that they managed to match
the weather conditions and the time of
day is very promising
by the way i want to quickly mention
this as i feel it's important
some people seem to assume that the
calamity itself spanned across multiple
days and some even suggesting weeks
and that linc and zelda might have had
to camp out at specific moments or
something like that
but i can assure you that this is not
the case the calamity only lasted about
12 hours tops
it starts at sundown when zelda returns
from the spring then the main invasion
and eradication of hyrule takes place
mostly at night which is also when zelda
awakens her power
then by the time zelda arrives at the
great forest to return the master sword
knight has turned to day
and then she continues to seal away
ganon of course the castle is covered in
dark clouds so it doesn't look like
midday in the scene
the calamity was a swift and merciless
defeat it's why there are so few
survivors the hylians were caught
completely off guard and barely had time
to evacuate anyone
besides do you really think that zelda
and link were able to camp out amidst
all of this i don't think so and if
you're still on the fence about this
both breath of the wild and creating a
champion refer to the event as the day
of the great calamity at multiple
occasions
anyway from this fact we can also derive
that this shot from the age of calamity
trailer takes place
around the same time as the scene where
zelda breaks down however still
slightly before it since zelda mentions
during the cutscene that the champions
are now
quote trapped inside those things but as
we can see here vana boris has not yet
been taken over and still maintains its
original blue glow
speaking of vana boris it's time for the
main event
aside from the sheer amount of guardians
blasting their way through central
hyrule the second thing that catches the
attention is that it's basically being
observed from her bosa's point of view
atop her divine beast
which brings up an important question
where exactly is vana boris located at
this point
and which part of central hyrule is she
observing what are we looking at here
i think most of us kind of assumed that
the divine beasts were roughly in the
same location as the firing positions we
saw in breath of the wild at the moment
they were taken over
which in vanna boris case is on
spectacle rock but as we can see in the
trailer spectacle rock is right here
with the wasteland tower right next to
it
so apparently vana boris was nowhere
near spectacle rock at that moment
so where is she the way the shot is lit
gives us very little to work with
as most of it is too dark to see any
definitive landmarks in central hyrule
turning up the brightness or the
contrast doesn't do much
there simply isn't enough pixel
information to work with
everything still just blends together so
the only thing we really have as a
reference is the skyline in the
background
now this is what i believe to be roughly
where the shot was taken from
which in the case of my shot here is
atop the shika tower located in central
hyrule
and herbosa as well as our divine beast
are looking in this general direction
we have the great plateau here and
spectacle rock here as a reference
that is pretty damn crazy since just
look at how close to hyrule castle that
actually is
but before we get into what this means
for the story let's first look at how i
came to this conclusion
because when we look at my shot and the
one from the trailer side by side we can
see that there are definitely some
significant differences
and this has to do with a number of
factors as mentioned before the horizon
is the main anchor point here
by matching up the alignment of various
shapes and structures we can get a
pretty accurate estimation of where
naboris is located on the x and y axis
on the map but as mentioned before there
are some significant differences between
the two compositions
first off in my shot we can see a lot
more of the horizon than in the trailer
if we were to crop out the part of the
skyline we see in the trailer it would
look something like this
so does this mean we are too far away
not necessarily
notice how this crossroad here is
visible in the trailer
yet in the cropped out version it falls
off screen the best explanation for this
difference is the type of camera being
used in the trailer compared to the one
in my composition
and in particular the focal length of
the camera for those who are unfamiliar
with how focal length works
it basically determines how wide or
narrow the field of view of the camera
is the longer the focal length the
narrower the field of view and vice
versa
some cameras have a dynamic field of
view while others have a static one and
can only change their field of view by
changing the lens
by adjusting the focal length of a
camera while simultaneously changing the
distance to an object you can actually
zoom in on the background while the
foreground object stays the same size
there are various reasons for using
either a long or short focal length
gopros for instance always have a very
wide angle lens
since you want to capture as much of the
environment as possible
something that's also interesting to
note is that the wider the lens becomes
the more the image gets distorted and
you get this spherical look as if you
can see the curvature of the earth on
the horizon
which of course in real life isn't
observable that's why the earth is flat
you can even see this slight warped
effect in my capture
of course i don't have any control over
the focal length of the camera in breath
of the wild but i made a little
demonstration of what this would look
like
all i'm doing here is changing the y
position of the camera while
simultaneously changing the focal length
of the camera
notice how we can see more and then less
of hyrule field but mount hylia stays
the same size
this wouldn't happen if i don't adjust
the focal length in this case the
mountains get smaller and bigger while
the camera moves back and forth
long story short the camera in the
trailer shot is likely using a different
focal length than the one in breath of
the wild
hence why the compositions are not
identical because of this it's
impossible to pinpoint the location of
vano boris with 100
accuracy but we can get pretty close i'm
fairly certain that in terms of the
x-axis and the angle of view we are
definitely on
point as stated before this is mainly
due to the alignment of different
elements found on the horizon
if we take the skyline from the trailer
and put it against the one from my shot
and then adjust for the field of view we
can see that they are very close
again there are factors which make it
impossible to get a 100
match such as the aforementioned camera
type but also the elevation
we don't exactly know how high vana
boris is and even if we did
it's unlikely that the model scale from
the trailer is the exact same as the one
found in breath of the wild
it might not even be the exact same
model who knows
i am standing on the central shika tower
which i'm fairly sure
isn't the exact same height as fauna
boris we also have to take into account
that the shot in the trailer isn't right
behind the divine beast
it's not actually a pov shot from
herbosa's eyes the camera is positioned
slightly to the left
and away from her and i will never be
able to get the camera in that exact
same spot
but it's the alignments which really
matter here and by observing these
alignments we can make pretty accurate
guesses as to where
certain landmarks are this little peak
here for instance is unmistakably the
rooftop of the temple of time
this shape here is in fact two different
mountain tops
one close and one much further away from
this alignment we can confirm that this
area right here
is the colosseum and this purple lit
strip is likely the bridge
leading to it this garrison or keep
right here matches with the ruin found
in front of the moat surrounding the
coliseum
the rock formation seen right above her
bosa seems to be
mount gustav etc and this is why i think
the angle of view and the exposition of
noboras is pretty accurate
if we even slightly move to either the
right or left of the position we're
currently at
the alignments completely fall apart
especially the mountain peaks as well as
the temple of time no longer match up at
all
when it comes to the actual field below
there are still some significant
differences
however i think most of that can be
chalked up to either some of the reasons
i mentioned before
or alterations done to the map of age of
calamity there seems to be a lot more
rock formations on the ground but
hyrule's geography could have changed in
between games
some rocks may have been blasted away or
eroded or
you know maybe even stomped into the
ground by ivana boris waltzing around
centro hyrule
which brings me to the final segment
with this rough estimate of the location
of vana boris in the trailer
what does this mean for the story well
aside from all the ruins in central
hyrule there's also a huge amount of
dead guardians found around these parts
and vana boris may have had a large
stake in this it might even hint at
and dare i say a playable section where
you are able to stomp smash
zap and electrocute guardians around
central hyrule which would of course be
absolutely amazing but let's not get our
hopes up too much
still the fact that urbosa managed to
get vanaborus onto the fields of central
hyrule all the way from gerudo desert
is pretty damn awesome and now that i
think about it the artwork shown at the
end of both trailers
actually shows vanna boris walking
around central hyrule in the background
very close to the castle we don't see
any other divine beasts in this artwork
either
so it might be that herbosa was the only
one to gather divine beasts this close
to ganon before it was finally corrupted
and taken over
i mean out of all champions urbosa has
by far the biggest grudge against ganon
due to the history which tells that
calamity ganon once took on the form of
a gerudo and just in case you were
wondering i'm not using this new
information to update the hero's path
episode about urbosa
the reason being that the paths laid out
in those videos are based on what we
know from breath of the wild and
creating a champion
and make gameplay suggestions based on
that the whole goal of the series is to
see
how this will ultimately stack up
against the story events presented in
age of calamity
anyway that pretty much wraps it up for
this one this turned into a much longer
video than i originally had in mind but
hey when in rome get it all right bye
[Music]
you